hey guys that's the Baker with Cross
Timbers bison you know one of the
questions I always get besides what's
the difference between bison and Buffalo
is do you have to have a permit to raise
bison what does it take to raise bison
[Music]
so guys what I want to talk to you about
today is how to start a bison herd
there's no perfect way of doing this
I'll just tell you my experience and
what I did I had a background in bison
and obviously loved this animal and that
experience back when I worked at the
National Park Service kind of led me
into you know the influence of getting
bison and so that first of all was the
encouragement of others and there's the
influence of a background history with
these animals I wanted to be able to
raise them so I had that inspiration
there and an encouragement of the family
members and my and my wife to do
something like this and so that was a
support system that I got that really
helps a bunch but there's several
different things that I want to talk to
you about today that will help you get
started
to be honest with you there's no special
permit there's no special license or
anything to raise bison these are not
exotic animals you know you're not
you're not raising animals that are from
a zoo I know there's bison in some zoos
but this is not an exotic animal this is
a natural species that occurs here and
basically you just treat them it's it's
kind of like cattle if you want to start
raising cattle for whatever reason you
want to start raising cattle for you can
do it you don't have to have any special
permit to raise bison you don't have to
set a special license or anything like
that you if you want to do it you can as
long as you have really good facilities
obviously to contain the Bison good
fencing and you kind of have a
background in it it would it would
definitely help but to be honest with
you if you've had experience raising
cattle then then you're not far off of
raising bison there are a couple
different things you know behavior
differences and and different handling
systems and and behaviors and more
stress there there is a difference
between raising cattle and raising bison
but if you do want to raise bison it's
not that difficult to start you just
need to get in contact with somebody
that raises bison maybe somebody in your
local area and that's where it starts
from there if you've had if you have
somebody local or somebody in your state
that you can contact and start from
there that that's probably the easiest
way to do it and they'll kind of point
you in the right direction I'll do
whatever I can to help I would love to
help you know I'm here in Oklahoma and I
can answer any questions that you have
for me that's not a problem you know I
just I got mine I got in contact with a
guy and I was just really lucky because
this guy happen to be a big-time bison
guy
and he's thirty minutes down the road
from our farm and so I was just really
lucky and I got a hold of DOC Parsons
and and he pointed me in the right
direction but I had experience raising
bison I say raising them taking care of
him handling him with my experience in
the National Park Service when I was in
college so I had some experience there
and I wasn't really scared to raise them
or be in the pen with them at all I was
a little nervous when you buy your own
herd but it's a little bit different but
you can do it you can definitely raise
your own bison okay those are not bison
but those back here bison I don't know
what's going on here but anyways yeah
you're you can you're more than welcome
to get in contact with me if you would
like to raise a bison if you if you have
some experience of raising cattle or or
bison and your own general and you want
to expand go for it I encourage you to
do so they're amazing animals and
they're fun to watch they're just
absolutely fun to watch they're hanging
out down here in our bottom pasture and
just enjoying life another resource that
you can reach out to is the national
bison Association it has a great
association when I go to the
conference's the Bison conferences
there's a summer conference and then
there's a winter conference the winter
conference is in Denver my wife and I
attended the last year had a great time
but you can even get on the website and
you can get contact information there
and that will be very helpful if you're
interested in raising bison that's
actually a good start and you can branch
off from there and figure out you know
maybe who's in your area maybe there's
somebody local that raises bison maybe
you've driven down the road and seen a
bison herd and you know if you can
figure out who owns those bison maybe
that's a good start
somebody within your state that raises
bison but you can always go to the
national bison so
see Asian look online I believe it's WWE
bison central.com and you can go on that
website and get a lot of good
information and there's a lot of good
contact information on there as well
[Music]
[Applause]
new this tree was good for something hi
Eleanor
feel good you got in your hair
hey guys I hope I helped you out today
I hope that I've encouraged you with
some of my videos to raise bison it's
not for everyone I hope that you guys
understand that these animals are very
different than cattle they're different
than any sort of livestock that if
you've ever raised livestock before
they're a very unique animal they're a
special animal and they have character
they are very very social animals which
that's so interesting about them which
that's one of the things that just will
attract you to them it's just how social
they are they have this this this family
and you know they you can see how they
interact with each other and and even me
as well in my family one more out here
but take your time and see if this is
the right thing for you go visit a bison
farm go and see how they operate you can
go to a large scale bison farm or you
can go to a small scale bison farm
obviously mine is smaller I started out
small and that's funny I think this is
easier to start out this way and by the
way Ted Turner started out with a very
small bison herd as well and he's the
largest bison producer and in the world
so it's ok to start out small but use
your resources dig into and get as much
information as you can go visit a farm
that's the best thing to do see how it
all are operates see how they do things
and and make a decision from there and
you know have a have a good background
of of raising animals that would be a
good start and you have to have good
property with that provides grass and
obviously good fencing which I'm going
to talk to you about an upcoming video
hey guys I hope you enjoyed the video
today I hope I've encouraged you to
raise some bison and I hope I've
released drawed some interest to you to
do that if you guys have any questions
anything you guys can contact
me you can go to my website Cross
Timbers bison comm you can check us out
on Facebook and Instagram and if you
already haven't followed us along and
check out our small herd here in
southern Oklahoma thank you guys so much